Det finns en och annan kreativant bennörer som förbånar oss över att man lockar till sig fel sors kunder.
Kunde som i fråga sätter eller som sällan eller kanske till med aldrig en öjda.
Eller som vi har mer än vad de är billiga betalar för. Du vet vi kan gärna.
Men att man gör det, att man lockar till sån här typen av uppdagshygbar. Det är inte särskilt konstigt allt faktiskt.
Utan det har nämligt stor att göra med ditt pris, att du är alls förbildig för en seriöse beställare.
Men att du där motpassar den som verkar då är seriöse eller för den delen av professionell liv man köper kreativar tjänster.
Och vitt mistag är att du sätter dina priser i relation till din desperation.
Och det är att din nåt som människor snappar upp.
Du signalerar ganska tydligt att du behöver en affare mer än kunde behöver dig.
Och det är en ting som den här dåliga kunden, märkel och sen absorben att tydligt sätter i scen och utnyttja.
Om du ställer till vänder på det, då kommer någonting helt annat att hända.
Ett högt pris sängliga nämligen att du ser dig själv som en investering, att du inte är till för alla.
Att du väljer om det du arbetar med som frövligt och kallas för integritet.
Och det här är viktigt att ha mer pengar är konkreta priser mot det ganska symboliskt.
Och priset berättar vem som är kvalificerad att köpa från dig och vem som inte är det.
Som andra ord, prisetning är inte bara ekonomi, det är långt mycket mer än så, det är positionering.
Så det väl kommer fram till det är att om du fortsätter att sätta dina priser utifrån desperation,
då kommer du också att fortsätta attrahera dåliga kunder.
Är det så däremot att du ändra på det om du vill använda då priset strategiskt?
Då skulle du börja med de här tre sakerna.
Number 1.
Om det känns för enkelt för det att sälja pris, då är det sannoligt förlågt.
För det finns ingen betala premiumfrågan som är som treka på sitt egna värde.
Och sedan då, nummer två, sluta förklara dina priser.
Du är inte på rej, utan du är en investering och kunder som måste övertalas om bitverde.
De blir oftast i ett största problem.
Och sedan då, nummer tre, prisetning är strategi och det ska så spegla din riktning och inte ditt nuläger.
För att sätta det pris utifrån vad du är idag, i så fall säljer du fortfarande en gammal version av dig själv.
Så frågan är inte varför gör som alla andra, utan frågan är varför du förväntade ett annat resultat.